[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal du mercredi 17 avril sur tv 78
c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
et régionale tout de suite les titres le
déplacement de nicole belloubet cet
après midi dans les yvelines la ministre
de la justice s'est rendu à la maison
centrale de poissy là où l'un des murs
d'enceinte de la prison s'effondrer en
mars dernier à la garde des sceaux a
visité les lieux avant de s'entretenir
avec la mairie et l'administration
pénitentiaire
la finale du concours d'éloquence de
l'ue vs qu se déroule demain soir et
pour cette troisième édition elle se
tiendra au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines
les hommes politiques sont ils des
comédiens le dilemme cornélien étiez
dramatique voici quelques-uns des sujets
que devront traiter les dix candidats en
lice et après trois ans de travaux au
château de versailles la chambre de la
reine et d'autres pièces du grand
appartement ouvre au public pour
l'occasion le site propose trois visites
consacrées aux souveraine française
découverte après l incendie de notre
dame de paris la solidarité s'organise
pour la reconstruction de la cathédrale
au delà de la grande collecte de la
fondation du patrimoine et des promesses
de dons et des fortunes françaises les
yvelines aussi se joignent pas l'élan et
nous vous parlions hier des subventions
de 20000 euros qui seront soumises au
processus au prochain conseil municipaux
est de saint germain en laye et
versailles le même montant devrait être
apportée par la ville de rambouillet
cinquante mille euros en tout de dons
pour l'agglomération versailles grand
parc et des aides financières également
prévues par maisons laffitte
marly-le-roi conflans sainte honorine
sartrouville ou encore coignières le
maire didier fischer proposera une
délibération en ce sens en séance enfin
le fonds de solidarité inter
départementale qui réunit les sept
départements d'ile-de-france dont les
yvelines apportera un soutien à hauteur
de 20 millions d'euros
dans l'actualité du jour la visite de
nicole belloubet à poissy la ministre de
la justice s'est rendu à la maison
centrale de poissy là où le 28 mars
dernier l un des murs d'enceinte de
cette prison à s'effondrait sur plus de
30 mètres de longueur est du côté de
l'avenue des ursulines la garde des
sceaux a visité les lieux pour constater
cet effondrement et pour rassurer la
population
elle a confirmé qu'un un diagnostic
serait fait dans les prochaines semaines
plus de potentiel investissements de
l'état est des travaux de sécurisation
du mur dès le mois de mai interview
collectées sur place par nicolas landry
amical et demi d'euros je me suis engagé
auprès de monsieur le maire comme auprès
de madame la directrice et des
personnels de l'établissement à ce que
nous ayons un schéma directeur
à la fin de l'année civile donc en
décembre un schéma directeur précisant
exactement ce que nous voulons faire de
cet établissement
à partir de là nous sommes en capacité
de mettre en place une programmation est
donc un calendrier des travaux qu'ils
l'accompagnent
à vue de nez si j'ose utilisé cette
expression c'est au tour d'une
soixantaine de millions d'euros sans
doute une action du collectif des
travailleurs migrants ce matin une
dizaine d'entre eux étaient devant les
locaux de l'urssaf à guyancourt à
l'appel de la cgt des yvelines ils ont
profité d'une visite de la députée de la
10e circonscription aurore bergé pour
l'alerter sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers les
manifestants dénoncent notamment la
situation de plusieurs personnes non
déclarés par leurs employeurs
aurore bergé qui a participé vendredi
avec six autres députés yves binois avec
à un échange pardon avec les équipes de
la caf du département la caisse
d'allocations familiales l'occasion de
faire le point sur les prestations
sociales et les problématiques
rencontrées par l'organisme reportage de
riz lyons mieux comprendre les missions
de la caisse d'allocations familiales
des yvelines afin de mieux aider la
population
voilà l'objectif de ces échanges entre
sept députés yvelinois issus de la
majorité et l'équipe dirigeante
c'est marquant en ce début d'année la
hausse du nombre de bénéficiaires de la
prime d'activité l'occasion de faire le
point sur sa mise en place dans notre
département nous avions anticipé
l'organisation avec à dispositif
d'accueil dédié en fait aux nouveaux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
avec une organisation également de back
office dédiées pour absorber le pic de
charge
donc c'est vrai que globalement malgré
le chiffre
l'augmentation importante de
bénéficiaires de cette prime consécutive
aux annonces gouvernementales
on a été globalement en capacité
d'absorber le choc de la réforme au 31
décembre 2018 dans les yvelines ont
compté plus de 235 me la locataire parmi
les sujets abordés lors de cette matinée
le recouvrement des pensions
alimentaires ou encore l'accompagnement
des bénéficiaires
objectif aller encore plus loin en
matière d'accès au droit
on a vraiment besoin qui beaucoup plus
d'interconnexions pour ne pas dupliquer
les choses mais aussi pour que les
informations qui parviennent alain
parviennent également à tous les autres
pour qu' on n'est pas encore une fois de
trous dans la raquette
une rencontre dans le cadre de la
stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
voulue par le gouvernement dès 2020 par
exemple le numéro pour joindre la caf ne
sera plus surtaxé
autre visite celle de jean-christophe
lagarde hier dans les yvelines le
président de l'udps il s'est rendu dans
une entreprise des clayes-sous-bois un
déplacement sous fond de campagne pour
les européennes dont l'élection se
tiendra le 26 mai prochain jean
christophe lagarde est la tête de liste
de son parti pour le scrutin écoutez le
au micro de marylène iapichino d'abord
lui dit de nombreux élus dans les
yvelines et c'était important pour moi
de venir les rencontrer rencontrer les
militants les sympathisants mais aussi
des citoyens qui s'intéresse à l'europe
on voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup
malheureusement de gens qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas encore dans la campagne
européenne on n'a pas eu le débat
européen au moment des présidentielles
il est impératif que nous ayons
maintenant parce que l'europe est à la
croisée des chemins
et puis les yvelines c'est quand même le
pays de jean monnet l'inventeur de
l'europe insulté aujourd'hui par
monsieur de villiers de façon indigne
mais c'est un peu nous qui en sommes les
héritiers
c'est demain jeudi la finale du
troisième concours d'éloquence de l'ue
vs qu elle se tient à partir de 18h45 et
pour la première fois l'événement se
déroulera sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour en parler sur ce plateau deux
invités et laine le maire et mélissa
seaman femmes ont formé dame
alors vous êtes hélène le maire en
études de géographie et d'aménagement a
lu vs qu première vice-présidente de la
fédération intéresse aussi ubuesque et
vous êtes l'une des co organisatrice du
concours mélissa seaman femmes vous êtes
également vice-présidente de l'intérêt
socio vs qu en parcours de droit en
parcours international pour des études
de droit à lui vécu et vous êtes chef de
projet de ce 3e concours d'éloquence de
l'ue vs qu une troisième édition donc
pourquoi un concours d'éloquence de lui
et ce q pourquoi organiser ce concours
donc le but de ce projet est de réunir
des étudiants issus de différentes
filières donc notamment celle du vécu et
de l'université de paris saclay autour
d'un projet commun donc le concours
d'éloquence de l'ue vs q donc par
exemple
hélène est étudiante en géographie et je
suis étudiante en droit et ça nous a
permis à ce projet de travailler plus
simplement ensemble avec d'autres
étudiants donc c'est ça les objectifs de
d'avoir ce genre de projet pour
travailler ensemble
c'est le but même de la fédération
d'associations donc on représente une
quinzaine d'associations sur tous les
campus de lever ce qu qui est présente
sur la totalité du territoire des
yvelines et donc on représente les 20
mille étudiants de l'uvsq soient toutes
filières confondues pour cette
fédération intérêt sauf celui vs
qu'alors l'éloquence et bien sûr l'art
de la bonne expression être capable
aussi de s'exprimer devant un auditoire
quels sont les secrets de la bonne
éloquence justement je dirais que elle
suppose une argumentation déjà un ton et
une clarté à la qualité de leurs
arguments sera donc primordiale et
ensuite l'action c'est-à-dire la voix et
leur gestuelle sera aussi prise en
compte et aussi la capacité je disais de
s'exprimer devant un auditoire devant un
public ça c'est aussi une difficulté de
l'éloquence justement exactement et
c'est pour ce cycle du cou on essaie de
pérenniser le projet pour cette
troisième édition
donc ce concours d'éloquence et nez
allie style écoles d'ingénieurs de
mantes-la-jolie a été repris par un
terrasse au la fédération de lui vs q
justement dell'agnola dès la seconde
édition dès la seconde édition nous
avons instauré un
accompagnement théâtre afin d'aider les
candidats pour la finale justement les
candidats reprennent le même sujet pour
la finale qu'ils auront la chance de
travailler avec des comédiens
professionnels
donc cette année nous avons choisi de
reprendre la compagnie des tisseurs de
songes décor justement pour accompagner
nos finalistes est justement de sortir
des amphithéâtres de la faculté pour se
produire sur la scène nationale du
théâtre de saint quentin en yvelines
alors justement d'être sur cette scène
du théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que c'est quelque chose
de particulier c'est une chance pour
pour ces étudiants c'est tout à fait une
chance oui même pour nous d'ailleurs
en premier lieu le théâtre est vraiment
de renommée régionale voire nationale et
c'est vraiment une opportunité qu'on a
eue de travailler avec ses équipes voilà
nous avons une soirée d'exception
vraiment une finale qui s'avéra être un
réel spectacle puisque ça stresse le
davantage les candidats d'être sur une
scène d'un théâtre national
effectivement les candidats sont de plus
en plus stressés sachant que nous avons
affiché complet au bout de deux jours
seulement
donc c'est une finale également très
attendue donc par les étudiants et
notamment les familles et le personnel
de la faculté
il y aura dix candidats en lice demain
pour cette finale au théâtre qui
sont-ils et ce qu'ils représentent
différents cursus au sein de lever ce q
donc nous avons eu des étudiants de
toutes filières qui sont venus se
présenter des ingénieurs des géographes
des juristes donc dans la finale il n'y
aura malheureusement que des juristes
d'accord mais voilà en tout cas au début
c'était une volonté c'était d'ouvrir le
logo à toutes les filières les candidats
les candidats sont de première année
jusqu'en master donc il ya quand même
une diversité des candidats qui vont
s'affronter sur plusieurs sujets tels
que lorca oui quels sont les exemples de
sujets gens venaient d'eux en titre sur
les hommes politiques et sur le dilemme
cornélien alors je venais plus le thème
en tête mais en tout cas il ya plusieurs
thèmes vent thèmes qui sont proposés
tout à fait on a essayé de proposer une
variété de sujets pour que chacun puisse
s'en inspirer
et montrer un petit peu ce qu'il est
capable de faire donc on espérait que ça
leur plaît vous en avez parlé de savoir
quelles ont été les étapes précédentes
pour arriver justement à cette grande
finale quelle étape ont vu à franchir
les candidats donc tout d'abord donc ils
ont dû candidater pour le concours
toutes les candidatures ont évidemment
été acceptée on a eu donc quatre phrases
quatre phases de présélection qui ont
été menées par aussi un jury comme lors
de la finale et donc ont été
sélectionnés dix candidats qui passeront
donc sur la scène nationale et qui ont
choisi un thème des débuts qui
présenteront ce thème
encore une fois demain comment va se
dérouler cette finale de combien de
temps disposent les candidats pour ce
concours d'éloquence
les candidats disposent de dix minutes
chacun maximum pour présenter leur texte
et argumentée dessus en tout cas
défendre leurs textes leurs thèses au
maximum nous aurons aussi à l'honneur
d'accueillir une étudiante de l'ue vs qu
il au nabot lucchi guitaristes
professionnels spécialisés dans le
phishing heures ce talent qui nous fera
justement un spectacle durant les durant
les délibérations
vous parliez les mains d'un jury qui
composera ce jury donc des directeurs
artistiques des directeurs de
communication des comédiens des juristes
et c'est uniquement ce jury qui va
départager les candidats ou est ce que
le public participe aussi à ce concours
à la finale également cris c'est une
surprise compétition puisque nous vous
réservons théâtre donc il faut venir au
théâtre pour connaître cette surprise on
peut assister bien sûr à cette finale
est-ce qu'il faut s'inscrire à l'avancé
il fallait justement s'inscrire sur une
billetterie gratuite et nous avons
affiché complet justement au bout de
deux jours cette billetterie qu'ils
affichent complet donc demain c'est
théâtre sept théâtres cette finale
pardon je rappelle c'est à 18h45 ça se
passera au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la finale bien
sûr de ce 3e concours d'éloquence de
l'ue vs qu mercier les le maire merci
mélissa seaman femmes d'être passé sur
ce plateau et vous êtes à l'organisation
toutes les deux à deux ce concours de
l'éloquence de lui
ce qu est l économie en bref accord
trouvé pour les salariés de sj à plaisir
en juin dernier les locaux de cette
société ont été incendiés et sont partis
en flammes ils ont été détruits pas de
réouverture depuis est la direction qui
a délocalisé son activité à villers
cotterêts dans l'aisne a lancé un plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi est les
nouvelles propositions faites dans ce
pse ont été validé hier par une grande
partie des soixante dix neuf salariés du
site
ces mesures prévoient notamment des
primes de reclassement plus importante
pour les plus de 50 ans à ce plan doit
être maintenant validé par la haye
direct la direction régionale du travail
nouvelle acquisition pour socotec le
groupe implanté à guyancourt vient
d'annoncer à l'acquisition de
l'entreprise britannique butler and
young qui agit dans le même secteur
celui du contrôle technique des
bâtiments et infrastructures socotec
ajoute ainsi 11 millions d'euros dans
son chiffre d'affaires l'objectif
affiché par le directeur général c'est
faire de s'auto socotec le leader
européen du marché du test de
l'inspection et de la certification et
ce dès 2020 c'est une activité qui
pourrait générer 130 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires en france la
silver economy aussi appelé l'économie
des seniors ce secteur lens aussi des
innovations comme l'entreprise blue line
et a installé à guyancourt nicolas
d'andoque le 11 novembre 2018 alain
tavernier est victime d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral
pendant sa convalescence il reste à son
domicile s'occupe en faisant des
maquettes
par sécurité il s'abonne au bouton
d'appel et détection de chute de blue
line est à relier à une plate forme
d'appel à taper dessus
il ya une petite lampe rouge qui est ça
qui s'allument donc voilà et à ce moment
là
moi j'entends qu'effectivement c'est
pris en compte tout fonctionne bien il
n'y a pas de problème merci beaucoup au
revoir quand je suis revenu à la maison
mes enfants ne voulaient pas que
je reste seule comme ma femme faisait
des courses ou avec ses activités me
laisser seul donc d'une part pour moi me
rassurer elle a rassuré elle aussi
directeur du développement chez blue
line et à xavier corbin vient faire un
bilan avec le client comme alain
tavernier près de 28000 personnes sont
abonnés à ce service d'accompagnement de
réconfort et d'assistance c'est un
dispositif qui s'adresse effectivement à
un public qui risque de chuter ou qui a
déjà chuté mais pas uniquement il faut
bien voir que sur l'ensemble des appels
que l'on reçoit dans 90% des cas on va
répondre à des à des demandes qui sont
des demandes de la vie quotidienne qui
n'ont aucun caractère critique aucun
caractère urgent la technologie est
également très importante pour la
sécurisation du transfert des
informations et le traitement de chaque
situation au siège de blue line et à
elancourt des opératrices sont chargés
de prendre les appels 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7
cette entreprise emploie aujourd'hui
près de 80 collaborateurs son activité
proposer des solutions pour les
personnes dépendantes
on voit régulièrement apparaître de
nouvelles solutions de nouveaux objets
je dirais presque parfois de nouveaux
gadgets qui sont plus ou moins
intéressants pour nos marchés
donc pour nous il est vraiment très
important de choisir les bons produits
de développer les bons produits
parce que la technologie est en fait
qu'un moyen de délivrer un service de
délivre une solution d'autres
technologies proposées le bracelet blue
garde destinée aux personnes atteintes
d'alzheimer
on voit l'équipe et de ce bracelet du
blue garde et elle va pouvoir se
déplacer à son gré le bracelet sa
fonction c'est de vérifier en permanence
que la personne est bien dans un
périmètre dans une zone de vie
prédéfinis et si elle venait à
s'éloigner trop et à sortir de cette
zone de vie automatiquement nous
recevrions une alerte sur nos
plateformes sahara la société a lancé
aussi un nouveau produit pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
un dispositif pour leur permettre de
jouer à des jeux vidéo
événement solidaire une compétition de
breakdance était proposée dimanche
dernier à magny les hameaux des dizaines
de danseurs se sont affrontés pour des
battles le prix pour assister à ce show
à donner des denrées alimentaires pour
des associations nickel et le mèneront
[Musique]
elle a le rythme dans la peau les six
rakoto une jeune breakdance de 25 ans
est venue de chilly-mazarin dans
l'essonne pour participer à la première
compétition de ce type organisée à magny
les hameaux
messi fait partie des dizaines de
breakdancers présent ce dimanche 14
avril à la maison de l'environnement
pour emporter les battles des duels de
deux minutes les sportifs doivent
improviser sur des sons venus du hip hop
se laisser un peu prendre par le som
réussir à mettre ces techniques et être
propre et efficace
mais quand tu es sur la musique tu
prends les gens avec noël public et ça
se fait naturellement
les sportifs sont ensuite jugé à la fin
de leur performance par un jury de trois
experts un jury il va juger au feeling
mais surtout sur des critères assez
simple comme
l'originalité
la musicalité la complexité des
mouvements et ça se
vote à main levée donc comme ils sont
trois voilà dès que la main se lève d'un
côté ou de l'autre
voilà il n'y a pas forcément de critères
définis pour le moment les battles qui
sont déroulées tout au long de
l'après-midi en parallèle l'événement
avait également une vocation solidaire
les organisateurs proposé au public et
aux participants de payer leur place en
donnant des denrées alimentaires pour
des associations
au total 120 kg ont été récoltés
[Musique]
découvrir les yvelines à prix réduits
c'est ce que propose le pass malin
présenté ce matin au conseil
départemental à versailles lancée par la
collectivité
cette carte permet de bénéficier d'au
moins 15 % de réduction sur les billets
d'entrée de 30 sites du territoire de
nouveaux lieux rejoignent l'opération
comme le château de versailles et les
jardins du château de dampierre ou
encore la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
on a un département d'une richesse
inouïe à la fois avec un patrimoine de
grande importance mais également sur une
découverte de la nature qui nous semble
évidente puisqu'on nous appelle le
poumon vert mais mais avec dégénéré des
possibilités de découverte incroyable ce
département mérite vraiment que les
yvelines oil des cours mais également
toutes les personnes d'île de france
puisque on a aussi beaucoup de touristes
d'île de france
bien sûr de façon internationale ou si
comme vous vous en doutez avec les
grands sites comme versailles pour ne
pas le citer le pass malin est
disponible dans tous les offices de
tourisme ou téléchargeable sur le site
internet qui s'affiche l'offre est
illimitée jusqu'au 31 décembre prochain
dont les sites du pass malin justement
je vous le disais le château de
versailles le monument qui met en ce
mois d'avril est les femmes à l'honneur
deux expositions et une réouverture sont
consacrés aux souveraine française trois
temps de visite que le public peut
découvrir jusqu'au mardi depuis depuis
mardi à 16 avril mélanie poké un plafond
révélé des détails retrouvez après trois
ans de travaux la chambre de la reine et
les trois autres pièces du grand
appartement s'ouvre au public un lieu
fréquenté par trois souveraine pas
structure avec ses grosses bordure
reprend celle du temps de la reine marie
thérèse
le décor a été très largement remaniée
pour la reine marie leczinska au moment
de la naissance du dauphin il ya eu
vraiment un changement de décor complet
donc l'ambiance générale de la pièce je
dirais plutôt louis case marie leczinska
mais marie antoinette pour sa part a
fait aussi beaucoup transformé la pièce
dans son ameublement un autre
appartement retrouve son décor celui
d'une presse que rennes à l'occasion
d'une commémoration
madame de maintenon meurt le 15 avril 10
719 le château propose une exposition
jusqu'au 21 juillet sur les pousses
secrète du roi louis xiv
elle ya vécu 35 ans est un lieu assez
emblématique puisque louis xiv lui a
octroyé cet appartement au moment où lui
donne une charge auprès de la dauphine
c'est à dire la brute de louis xiv il
trouve cette astuce pour lui donner un
appartement
on a beau être la maîtresse du roi on ne
peut pas être logés gratuitement à
versailles le château met aussi à
l'honneur une reine dont on parle peu
marie leczinska souveraine pendant 42
ans épouse de louis xiv la reine
polonaise se révèle à travers ses goûts
on voit aussi se dessiner un goût pour
certains peintres comme nattier comme
oudry on voit aussi se dessiner son goût
pour des sujets légers comme des
pastorales on met pas la même chose dans
le grand appartement d'apparat et dans
l'appartement intérieur et on voit aussi
se dessiner son goût pour la
conversation
elles forment autour d'elle un cercle
d'érudits trois visites trois lieux pour
découvrir celles qui ont marqué
l'histoire de france et l'histoire du
château à la commanderie à elancourt
cette exposition depuis le 5 avril
dominique leroy propos son jardin nos un
jardin zen en mouvement composé est de
végétaux l'artiste qui invite à la
déambulation une nouvelle fois mélanie
poker
un curieux jardin a pris place à la
commanderie des plantes récoltées sécher
et assemblé l'artiste dominique leroy
appel à la déambulation avec son jardin
d'eau une inspiration venue tout droit
du pays du soleil levant
c'est un théâtre donc théâtre médiéval
japonais très lent avec toujours à côté
un petit groupe de musiciens qui
accompagnent les comédiens et qui joue
essentiellement des percussions très
très sobre très basique
ça fait une ambiance un petit peu solal
est fixé des petits moteurs les plantes
se frottent étape entre elles comme des
caisses de résonance lors son deviennent
musique au coeur de la chapelle
dominique leroy a été invité par david
de rôle aux chorégraphes ont carte
blanche
c'est sa sensibilité sa poésie et la
magie de ses installations en mouvement
et qui produisent du son mais vraiment
dans du contemplatif dans la rêverie
ce qui me touche c'est lui avec vraiment
voilà il ya pas mal d'électronique on
sent qu'il ya vraiment un gros travail
de composition derrière mais c'est pas
non plus qu'on remarque le pouce un
travail par ordinateur invisible pour le
public
l'oeuvre créée en 2017 est à voir à la
commanderie jusqu'au 19 avril
ah et puis pour refermer ce journal
votre rendez vous du mercredi qui
revient à la visite dans nos salles de
cinéma du territoire ce soir direction
les yeux d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole la
programmation au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude au cinéma les
yonnaises à cette semaine nous vous
proposons une soirée spéciale john
carpenter la c1 méfie cinéaste favoris
donc forcément j'en fais beaucoup mais
c'est surtout parce que il ya beaucoup
de ces films qui ressorte ces derniers
temps et puis parce que c'est un
cinéaste important des années 80 aux
états unis mais qui a influencé le
cinéma mondial
alors on avait passé the thing on a
passé les aventures de jack burton dans
les griffes du mandarin et puis là on va
vous faire une soirée trois films de
john carpenter puisqu'il y en a quatre
qui ressorte qui sont ressorties cette
année le premier film ce sera un vase ou
los angeles
alors c'est un film qui est étrangement
intéressant aujourd'hui parce qu'en fait
c'est un film qui parle de le monde dans
lequel on vit maîtrisé par des
extraterrestres qui seraient cachées etc
mais quand on met des lunettes de soleil
spéciales on arrive à les voir et à voir
que toutes les publicités sont des
messages incitatifs à obéir sans dormir
regarder la télé etc etc
le deuxième film qu'on va vous proposer
ses seins mais petit chouchou c'est un
des plus connus c'est le film qui a fait
que john carpenter est un peu arrivé au
sommet c'est donc encore et toujours
avec snake plissken new york 1997 grand
grand film dans un futur improbable new
york manhattan est devenu
une prison et donc on
on retrouve notre héros qui doit sauver
le président tombé dans cette prison et
puis le dernier the fog a le seul vrai
film d'horreur de la soirée qui interdit
aux moins de 12 et qui donc sera
présenté en fin de soirée
je me ferai un plaisir de vous
accueillir de vous présenter tous ses
films et de vous dire tout ce que je
sais sur ce cinéaste et je vous promets
qu'on passera une très très bonne soirée
tous ensemble donc à vendredi 19 avril
dès 19h30 au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
le cetud journal également disponible
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv
soixante dix huit dans un instant le
séduit débat la question du jour petit
déjeuner gratuit et quand il a un euro
est efficace pour lutter contre la
pauvreté or ils iront et ses invités à
retrouver dans un instant quand à moi je
vous retrouve dès demain 18h pour une
nouvelle édition en direct d'information
locale belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]